- well it's been a long break but we are
back we are back in black is what one
people say but I'm not black I'm a white
guy our logo is black our logo
well no no there's that one community
says we're back in black what is back in
black who's that one comedian back in
the feel like context is everything
Louis black so I can't be back in black
I'm back in white back and still white
that sound good is this a rough start
well something has never changed it is
good to be back Wow back in black yes
ela we have a new look that is black
kind of I thought that's what you were
gonna dig that new logo he's gonna make
something ambiguously not racist
obviously but just something that makes
you uncomfortable yeah it's all
inclusive you got all the colors in the
spectrum man when you take a break first
of all we're here with Jack and Eric I'm
not just gonna sit here and pretend like
you guys aren't here just we've been
gone for a long time and I wanted to
address my people it's been like since
last no two Christmases ago since we've
been on this that's right that's out
really out oh damn when were they last
on yeah he's right it was and it was
December 2018 2019 even count them no
I'm gonna just wipe that whole year out
of my memory I'm fine I don't need it it
wasn't the best year whatever you know
okay it feels like it's only been two
months now yeah hey I took a month break
from the podcast and I was getting um I
was over it I was was ready to come back
I wanted to come back and work man
there's nothing more depressing than
just like sitting at home with nothing
to do when you're totally over it I was
fired up we were when I came in he was
doing pull-ups
Ethan was just snortin blinds of coke
these guys are fired up they're ready to
come back yeah who's gonna be a hell of
a show I have been actually pull up you
Wallops not pull up but exercising no so
what exercise I'm getting in shape all
kinds yeah cardio weights both TRX ins
urine he's got ropes and ropes involve
all medicine ball mmm
she's getting ready to poop out another
baby we're trying to squirting her
that's lovely you guys have picked up
some medical terms yeah you spend enough
time around a gynecologist don't read
like so when did you squirt in her
exactly right what he meant is when did
you guys conceive oh I thought like you
meant like spit he may have meant that
what I don't think yeah so the kids are
calling it these days but what about you
guys and are you guys trying to give
birth anytime soon we've been trying
yeah I mean I'm putting on weight but
it's not good as a baby oh no it's just
I've been eating a lot of cheese steaks
cheesesteak hoagies I gotta tell you I'm
not a fan of the cheese stick that's
okay
but you're from not yeah fine you get a
good cheesesteak around here honest yo
yeah actually yes please there's a place
called booze and there's one in Silver
Lake and there's one in North Hollywood
and they fly in the rolls from Philly
Amoroso roll thank you I mean I guess
you can make them but like a cheesesteak
isn't a very impressive meal it's sort
of just like stay comes all chopped up
yes
Cheez Whiz which is not actually cheese
it's cheese yeah I think so I mean the
the you could get a provolone on it but
like something ghetto where is wit is
cheese whiz and grilled onions on steak
sounds actually yeah absolutely
horrifically staple so wait wait I
thought they were all that's what
they're protective about I haven't met
many protective Philadelphia people
about anything
other than like their parking spots
mm-hmm
I guess that's a misunderstanding it's
about it yeah they like the team's
constantly lose and unless they go all
the way they either lose horrific Lee or
they are the way the whole thing and the
whole thing now it's very ridiculous
it's like they're okay so who's the hero
of Philly like is rocky they build a
statue out of this guy the hometown hero
he [ __ ] loses in the first movie he
doesn't make it
yeah they make a whole nother movie just
for him to win so that's Philly to me at
least just the cheesesteaks not even
that cuz I could find them here the
rolls in a little slice of home damn
I've always been shocked by your your
disinterest in Philly because I'm not
from Phil I am from the East Coast but
I'm not from Philly and I love Philly I
feel like I really more than you do and
you're out yeah from the place I'll
definitely miss Philly woody Philly I
love I love the city life I love just
what about every other city it's good no
you look different
it's cozier the people are friendlier
they're not flaky as they are in LA it's
a different vibe a whole different vibe
in Philly Philly is March charming Lane
it's charming that's the word I've been
there once once well then the thing is
we went there with John and jumped the
lens that John casts on the city is that
he hates it he's like a New Yorker he
looks down on Philly oh I can imagine me
New York people hate Philly
yeah difference between by the way New
York people are the worst people maybe
in the world and I'll tell you why
they're just a bunch of bitter [ __ ]
yeah they hate LA I went to New York and
everyone's talking [ __ ] on LA I was like
whoa like we're supposed to have some
rivalry but I didn't know we were in a
rivalry does everybody in LA is just
[ __ ] happy and joyful right but all
the New Yorkers that move to LA they're
the best right because they it's almost
like getting out of a cult it's like
you're breaking out of Scientology but
when you go in you or can you're like
I'm moving to LA they go why I was like
do you not have you been to LA do you
know anything about LA and they're like
'no people who grew up
la tend to want to move to New York for
a little bit too and I say a little bit
because they want to go there but then
winter hits and they're like oh [ __ ]
this yeah
this place smells and it's cold that was
zero degrees and it still smells like
piss yeah doesn't piss freeze the
concrete is soaked like a carpet God is
just like well here's my toilet [ __ ] on
this place yeah yeah and in Central Park
somehow I noticed that it always smells
like dog [ __ ] you notice this phenomenon
when you excuse me please
part of me everybody yeah you notice
when you walk past a dog [ __ ] the cement
follows you for uncannily long time yeah
it's like your nose is like mmm it's
like anonymous how can I be you're like
30 yards away 50 yards away yet the
smell lingers explain that check well I
was I was I can't follow because I can't
relate because I avoid Central Park
every time just because of the horror
stories I hear Oh Central Park's great
Oh only good part of the city really
because I thought that's where like all
the [ __ ] you get REME uh gangs and
killings happen they're welded so the
park is huge no sprint no no no he's
right that's where you go to get raped
or [ __ ] a dude in the bushes that
happens too but the park is huge that
happens I swear to god you walk there at
night and there's you see a gay dude you
could tell he's gay you could tell but
he wanders off dude well you could tell
by certain indicator he walks up but he
want his dick yeah that's like that
giveaway and he's and he's walking and
then he like goes off the path into the
bushes
dudes [ __ ] in Central Park that's a
known phenomenon but the park is huge if
you're in the South Park near you know
Midtown then it's very fun and jovial
the more you go up he's looking at 80
9100 Street that's where you're gonna
get a dick in your butt like it's tough
to for me to imagine no but they're
shady there's little there's definitely
places where I feel nothing I would say
would not walk there alone at
night though that's that's a big thing I
said now god ascribes all of New York
yeah okay yeah there you go
yeah and vent Philly I mean when I lived
in Philly I will walk to the only place
that wouldn't card me so I could get big
old twelve packs of lions head it was
called is cheaper it was cheaper than a
PBR Wow lions head is that a local
brewery maybe probably not undergo they
doesn't make its own stuff cheaper than
PB are cheaper than PBR how much was it
for a twelve hour it was like I think it
was like seven or eight bucks something
that's competitively priced and I'd walk
like 10 blocks to get it but it was
always it was like a like a video game
coming back I'd be like I'm gonna get
hurt on that that route I'm gonna go
around
I'll see you've got a prize beer mm-hmm
yeah I've beer really is that they're
like well I have an ID but I don't have
the money and I don't feel like walking
I'm just gonna go run this guy over you
ever think about doing that yourself
what knocking someone out and thicker
beer yeah yeah we've all played I did it
the Jaclyn's
that's true knocked his ass and you know
what I would have done the same I can't
blame you I'm not even mad didn't even
have beer those free well I do have some
white wine we have some lovely
assortment I want to see that gadget
you've got yeah we're all of you so this
is a Katherine's vineyard now it's just
like oh you are a lush oh my god you
want all these Wow Wow
first off we are first of all you can't
come with this [ __ ] not be judged
you can't gank jazz you can't come right
without what that's really the joke was
headed and I'm just a dirty evil no you
can't cut you first of all I'm sure the
mustache like that you come buckets what
what mustache well my little framer
curry thing going on here there's a
story behind this do by the way really
boring one
that is kind of cool right but for
someone who likes one it just feels like
a little insecure to me you know okay I
don't like the the gadgets that you know
make you do it by hand I you ever break
the core that's scared all the [ __ ]
time that's why I get that or that I
really but that that was a perfect open
and it's like that every time but it's
like you gotta carry whoa Jeff what Jeff
was linking it back and forth making it
being a melee weapon
this thing's a pieces didn't really
exert must for plastic a pro oh Christ
but I listen honey I'll buy you another
one
I got you one of these for Christmas
anyway so I just wanted them I didn't
know you already had one sighs now we're
right now that looks like a weapon
though but ya know I could do some
damage push the button does it work oh
yeah you're still good I'll buy it I'm
very sorry I didn't know that was gonna
happen it's very embarrassing boys my
face red okay you thing is I'm I've have
a baby and and I've just I have changed
I get it so how let's let's talk about
this let's discuss well I had a baby and
I gotta go take care of him thank you
and I'm very sensitive to alcohol I have
a tendency to a little bit make a fool
of myself as drawing doors you know Wade
yeah it's way too much this is enough
you know yeah the baby's great and it's
weird to be drunk around a baby yeah
yeah I can't even be drunk around my
puppy it's apparently the Parenthood so
when are you guys having babies though
you got married you got so what's going
on you should like my aunt is it baby
I appreciate to ask that question it's
not it's here's the deal I trust you
guys and that's fine but like anyone
else I think it went when it's like an
exponent expectation when it's kind of
like literally like an aunt saying yeah
it's like back up yeah but I like on a
podcast that's a different thing yeah
stinky
great that's the wine it's a Chardon
nose like Central Park I'm here we have
a juggler like the sharpening the
chardonnay the sharp discharge um well I
only asked you because we're in you know
front of nearly a million people no
naturally uh no we we talk about it all
the time and I think we we do want to
have you but like we're not actively
personally trying we're yeah we're we're
getting there we're like we're kind of
warming up to the idea we're talking
about like not right now but within the
nice I mean we were down I am a 31 she's
32 32 okay yeah we had that time when we
both kind of like started to talk about
it that we definitely want to do it but
like not right now yeah kind of thing
well wouldn't yeah and then when we
decided was kind of where were like well
this seems like a good time yeah let me
ask you this do you ever feel it was
there a point where you ever felt where
I write read it yeah no I'm just kidding
where you felt ready because like the
whole thing yes like we don't feel ready
we want to be selfish we want to like
travel yeah we were both kind of like
looking at each other and it's like this
is kind of a good time yeah like
probably as ready as we're gonna be
yeah cool yeah for sure
I'm surprised to hear the pleasantly
surprised because the typical answer I
usually hear is like you're never ready
there's never a good time well that
statements that you always hear is
[ __ ] nobody do that you're never
prepared to raise you're really prepared
and you're never gonna know everything
that's true but also but no one knows
for knows we're all we're all kind of
guessing sorta yeah yeah this wine is
really nice yeah you like it right yeah
it is buttery okey I don't know oh sweet
oh yeah is it
but I will tell you that it can take it
can take like it can take a while so you
should frequently do you do it what's
your favorite position alright in order
know I'll spare in honor of my wife I'll
spare the gory details but gore
[Laughter]
let me answer that question with a
question okay has it not answered at all
but how like how hard is is Parenthood
or what like in the initial throes of it
like the Apple I the first two months
are awful okay the worst awful well we
had a specially bad time with him but it
was like a colleague baby which means
gassi gassi and super like like you
would feed him and then it's a whole
three hours of drama because he's
uncomfortable and spitting up and crying
and you don't know if he's still hungry
or not hungry and you're over fighting
him or you didn't it's just kind of like
you gotta dial it in it was a mess but
that was the first two months okay and
and then from like month as soon as he
like passed at first two months every
every week it started to get easier
gotcha yeah we're in month seven now
right seven and now it's only getting
better it's like it's so sweet and he's
starting to learn things like every week
is learning something new every day
pretty much you see something new that's
oh that's gotta be fascinating yeah it's
real and even in the hard time it's like
it's so amazing it's not like you're
gonna regret it it's you know what I
mean
oh yeah I don't think anyone should like
that it's not hard it's really hard
well you won't be able to go anywhere
you won't be able to hang out with
people that much mm-hmm you'll always be
at home I mean you can go out with the
baby but he did he's not good for that
long it's right really important to get
help as much as you can okay really
important so you can still get the house
sometimes still do something have you
had like family come help at all yeah
yeah well you want a housekeeper or or
in any or anything but just like get
yourself help and don't feel like you
got to be the hero and do everything
cool that's what will ruin your life
yeah and that's why poor people are so
miserable because they can't do that
stuff I mean it's it's to be poor dude I
mean that's right if you don't have the
money it's important to be in your
family because they won't help you
wrinkly I mean you know it's one or the
other if you don't have family Iran
we're lucky to have his mom who does
help us but it's still not enough so
I could use 10 moms to be frank yeah I'm
sure it's never enough but the truth is
actually having being a parent
highlights how like privileged you are
to have money it's easy to forget but
even just enough money like buying a
crib and buying diapers and buying food
and getting help and all these little
things that don't bother me I mean that
was part of the reasons that we were
waiting because for a while we felt like
we weren't we didn't even have a stable
income or didn't even know what we're
gonna do the next week like yeah oh I
don't know single parents to it boy he's
like you hear about these like these
moms in the inner-city raising three
kids by herself I'm like bro that's like
her oke said I know how that's even
possible
so kudos to those uh for those moms out
there that's why being Amish probably
rules really it's probably the best
thing about being Amish is like you have
your whole family and community dude
build you a crib yeah they go babies out
there like okay here's the crib and want
us to build it a house well we all work
here yeah we're not really leaving it
takes a village a fee and I've heard it
that mental illness is very uh very
slight among the amount of incest that
I'm assuming community well maybe that's
yeah that's gotta be in there right I'm
not making that up
like that's so tiny and dads do are the
Amish inbred look that up wait well I
think incest is in all communities all
around the world
Amish well real family no one's safe the
royal family Amish the Queen the Jew
well I mean ashkani or yeah Ashkenazi
Jews were all inbred that's where we all
have all these really neurological
diseases what [ __ ] because back in the
day we had our little village and we
[ __ ] ran around in our little suits
look nobody wanted to [ __ ] us so [ __ ]
each other and to be honest there's like
stinky soot we're like bro you have to
be you have to be very generous to [ __ ]
a Hasidic Jew right uh
I mean while I've lived in Israel for
five years so there they wear the suits
they got the hats they don't shower
nearly enough one of the million degrees
outside they stock the black suit they
stink bro they stink and you know they
don't shave you seen their face imagine
what their dicks look like wait I always
thought those were like fake that is
commitment yes yeah we're gonna do it
their faces look so gnarly so imagine
what these dudes look naked and they're
all pretty fat too cuz that you know
that wife's at home cooking that's all
she does all fat well a lot of the ones
you see are pretty chunky picture yeah
let's see this yeah you asked for so
Eric what about you man my tooth hurts
you know I typed that and the first
thing that come up is Jewish form what I
typed fat Hodgkin's weren't Jewish born
and there's nothing good came up all I
see is a bunch of crap it's just like a
family dinner well okay so any other
questions about Parenthood well I was
gonna deflect a bit to Eric and ask like
you know you and you and Sam you ever
have the kid talk oh when we need a kid
we'll get one okay fair enough
that's gonna be older than two months or
she just get that yeah yeah whatever
we're gonna name it it's a choose it I
think this is a year old and be like
what are you and it's gonna be like like
Power Ranger Tyrannosaurus like you got
it that'll be the first time it ever
hears the English language in fact it'll
be talking like Nell like now nobody
gets my Nell jokes I make jokes about
the movie no never heard of the movie -
Jodie Foster movie okay where they find
a feral child or like a barrel woman in
a cabin and she doesn't know English oh
you know what language there's a fit
there's a filly podcast radio show we
listen to every morning Preston and
Steve and they use a sound bite of a
from Mel and I think it's that it's like
this thing like gibberish like in it
it's like a feral child make their own
language I think it's from that movie I
sure hope so
otherwise it's all it's an offensive
sound but
no it's a feral kid she's like
intelligent she just doesn't quite have
a grasp on [ __ ] snuck in a cabin in the
woods we kept there we can't make fun of
her jack
Wow I think we can cancel there's only
one of her I'm surprising humorless fat
hairy Hasidic Jew bah and now you're
openly making fun of ya [ __ ]
spaceship so corkscrew now guys I have
an update about that Amish being inbred
broke that anyone want to hear this oh
wait you found out yeah almost all
honest descend from about 200
eighteenth-century founders that's crazy
genetic disorders that come out due to
inbreeding exists in more isolated
districts so that means damn that the
people who are more isolated they can't
find other amich from other communities
to rub dicks with or you know not dicks
because probably being gays not cool
with animals and also you can't
reproduce when you rub dicks go ahead
and to you yeah I I can verify that
rubbing dicks does not make you pregnant
there you go Amish mixers you know Amish
communities need are at the Philadelphia
Zoo well that's another Philly thing
like you go the Phillies ooh and these
[ __ ] Amish people everywhere oh they
love the zoo animals Aaron yeah being
for work the buggy so there's a bunch of
buggies no some of them can drive where
they take the bus like the the thing
about [ __ ] poser I'm not an Amish
expert by any means but they use
electronic it sounds like you are giving
baby maybe the older ones are a little
more so what's Griffith what's what does
it mean to be Amish if you're using
electronics I don't know I think that's
it that's what they're all are they all
Quakers Mennonites
I guess there's different wines yeah
Mennonite is the one that I think use
some electronic stuff I think that
they're pretty serious about I don't
think they use any anything electric so
a Mennonite is just a fake Amish person
they definitely drive
I mean I know when you turn six yeah I
think that there's like a little bit of
it really like well well the Amish have
the Rumspringa which yeah where when
they turn I guess it's 16 I thought or
something they're allowed to go
experience the world for a while kingpin
and decide but if they decide to stay in
the world of the modern their entire
family shuns them yeah they get
condemned let go have fun out there
yeah yeah I mean what are you gonna pick
you're gonna pick your family are you
gonna work yeah yeah the one with the
iPhone is the world there should be a
TLC show about that the Amish oh sorry
it's a bursary bubble guys watch any
shows on TLC once that I'm gonna bring
up 66 hundred pound life honestly I'm I
don't watch the show religiously but I
see like if a clip pops up am I
recommended you know as you know to go
clips small bite that's my favorite my
sister really likes that I even tried
that one yeah
god I hate all those [ __ ] people and
I mean hate oh no no not your sister the
people on the show and I'm is she a 90
day fiancé
well she is so you're gonna judge
already get out it's all just a goddamn
excuse for green cards odd I'm trying to
find this club to show you guys what
about The Bachelor yeah okay a little
I'm a little underwhelmed for now am
Soule is the worst fact he's so boring
yeah just kind of like I agree he's no
Hannah I want them to have it and Hannah
ruined the show I don't want to see her
dumb [ __ ] face there was a lot of
Hannah in the first like two episodes it
was it was it was the Hannah show yeah
but a Luke P show you don't watch that
[ __ ] do ya ya ya [ __ ] is Anna yeah I
guys say so just my one little admission
of guilt here is um I never like before
last year
you never watch The Bachelor I was gonna
say never watch this Bachelorette
blissfully ignorant we're pretty down
you know and I was like nah it's all
trash level so Aaron goes to me and says
I can we just watch this can you watch
this with me like well I need like some
often like it's something to talk about
at the office I need the show we're
watching it and can you just wash this
with me well well if fun we'll drink
wine and I'm like all right sure what
the hell so we watched the Hannah season
last year I could not stop [ __ ]
laughing like the first episode I was in
tears laughing because it's just such a
shitty premise it's literally literally
thirty dudes all lined up and they just
they all fight for like time with Hannah
and they're all throwing themselves over
the stranger and they're all like I
don't know I just feels really genuine I
feel like we just click and it's like
they've known her for five minutes yeah
they yeah and then the best part the
best part of the show is like one guy is
seated with Hannah on a couch and he's
explaining to her like how he and his
girlfriend like lost their first kid
together like he's doing the sobs
meanwhile another guy butts in ham ABC
always began yeah he comes in he's like
oh can I look speak to her for a few
minutes and like wow this guy is doing
this [ __ ] stops it's the funniest
[ __ ] I could not stay BC that was
amazing I was Luke P and loopy it's just
it's really it's it's trash it's good
not defending it in that way but it's
also the funniest [ __ ] you like don't
watch it because you like it you
understand that I feel like my time
spent like no it's not blood it was
better spent watching this never watch
it alone but watching it with Aaron
watching it with someone yes you are a
body chard I'm like I'm so sensitive to
cringe and like those shows me first
that's great I don't watch it like this
I've seen 90 day it's not like yeah and
it's just like I'm like watching a
horror movie I'm like close my [ __ ]
eyes
you watch it by yourself no no it's just
on in the goddamn room when I walk in
like what do you watch
yeah what do you watch yeah Eric if your
soap if you're better than us
no have you guys seen my mirror it looks
good everyone this Eric what's this you
tell me you don't watch the show much
I've seen exactly because it was
trending I'm listening huh okay that's
Casey 707 baby
now we're talking and I still haven't
watched this just dish so I do it except
just clips look at this shot how cruel
are they set that shot up calculated
they're like alright let's get on the
floor the tripod [ __ ] ball we only
brought this little town he makes me cos
I thought the woman was gonna get in
there I was like oh man she's pretty
bitten in this guy yeah you're gonna
have to move around like almost like a
pig
in a way and wallow I watched one
episode and I was riveted but it's so
sad it's not like 90 day fiancé with a
bunch of comedy of air watching yeah
yeah talk about something give up with
him he's over to a thing you'll see what
it's all the dads too old to be like
still raising his son right yeah that's
a straight-up Arby's cup that he's
bathing with listen to the sounds just
just enjoy the sound okay it's really
like yeah you know the sounds are
incredible this I fall asleep to this
I'm afraid to you back in there again
right well I got this thing I can buy
it gets oh sorry I gotta go back guys I
miss the good sound it's just a super
difficult process that's that there for
like nine hours just couldn't give up in
life tragic me up and we realize I was
like that I just
I'm afraid to you back in there games
right I got this thing I can buy that
wait what was that
let me go back one more time shoulders
that's what I use
me too head shoulders is the same you
stop using it you get a shitload of
dance right I just used it because I
like the smell that's the one time and
then I'm so sorry to interrupt but this
is the sound of like a bad way to be
13 million views why do you think that
is do you think it's kind of like people
are why zag I think I think they can't
like they can't wait away I think
they're like like this is like you don't
see this every day I think it's the art
of TLC they mastered YouTube recommended
this was like on that to TLC they
mastered like exactly what you shouldn't
be watching but they know everyone's to
know why way I feel like people I'm not
like that and they all I think they I
think people watch this to feel good
about themselves I think it's just it's
it's just it's a crap
it's a credible look at this shot Jackie
was telling me people you don't know why
people are watching look at that put up
my head yeah I mean like it shouldn't be
his dad doing that I just feel really
bad well yeah job like this is like it's
taking care of his son that he shouldn't
have to take care she'll see plan yeah
is this I think like right that you
don't know where that's at wait if
without having frightening yeah some
kind of trauma or mental disorder
something yeah jack is this his [ __ ]
head or is that fat that's fat Nathan so
it's where's [ __ ] be like you a down
leading the fifth way lower you gotta go
to break be right here right in that boy
we got okay we got to go to break well
we'll pick this up when we get back
right we'll pick up a right off where we
came back we've got a live one yet are
you guys enjoying this right Jack and
are we doing work screw can you guys
tell me how much is it
oh I my okay I'm going to break gank go
to break
Lila if I could recommend one product to
you to immediately make you and your
home and your family safer what would be
exactly you read my mind
ring let me tell you about ring
revolutionising the game forever
they invented this beautiful little
doorbell right oh so you got a doorbell
you ring it Bing bong people know you're
home wait let's make it better put a
camera on it so when people ring you can
open it on your phone and see who's
there
wait make it even better put a
microphone on it so you could talk to
them through your phone to the front
door wait make it even better give it
motion-activated sensors so that when
people approach your door
it automatically warns you in case
somebody's creeping on your house or
whatever they do and up there maybe it's
just a critter that's interesting also
and then make it even better beam it up
to the cloud immediately so that if some
slick what it was the robbers name in
home alone the soggy bandits the weapons
the Wet Bandits I like soggy better in
case you've got some slick soggy bandits
trying to cut your internet it's already
on the cloud it's a beautiful product oh
and make it even better make a
floodlight those are already great and
you've already got them around your
house but now it has all the features of
a ring except you've got an alarm you
could talk to them you could call the
police actually I don't think you can do
that we could hit what's a little arm
you don't need to do that the raiding
floodlight is incredible every ring
product is incredible you've got an HD
video two-way audio features it's gonna
make you feel a trillion times safer
when you're out of the house you're
gonna feel a trillion time saver because
again it's a game changer what can I say
it's ring as a listen you have a special
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now with a video doorbell and
motion activated floodlight camp the
starter kit has everything you need to
build a ring of security around your
home so go to ring.com slash ashley
that's ringing comm /h through
six percent of men lose their hair by
age 35 that's tragic and it's avoidable
like heart disease but still I'm gonna
have a heart attack at this rate so sir
some things you can't avoid is what I'm
trying to say even if they are
preventable what you notice thinning
hair it could you know what I'm saying
once you notice thinning hair it could
be too late
is that hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet it's the
best way to prevent more hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have some it's time to grab that new
year´s by the follicles baby hears
through a year of personal growth hair
growth that is why do you guys turn to
weird solutions or new nothing when they
can turn to medicine and science
introducing for Hanscom a one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care sexual wellness
for men has time to write a new chapter
one in which you have hair dang I like
that chapter I read that chapter hymns
is helping guys
be the best version themselves with a
licensed physician and fda-approved
products to help treat hair loss there's
a not snake oil or gas station counter
supplements you goof this prescription
solutions backed by science and was
created by a guy who knows that some
men's health conversations are either
online in person we got no more awkward
and personal doctor visits or for long
Pharmacy lines for hims connects with
real doctors online which could save you
hours completely confidential indiscreet
gonna answer a few quick questions the
doctor will review and they were
determined if it's right for you they
can prescribe you the medicine to treat
your hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door so let's get that year
started right with the beaut beautiful
locks with hymns dive into 20/20 hair
first ela right now my listeners can get
started with the first month free go-to
for hams calm slash h3 that's four hymns
calm slash h3 prescription requires an
online consultation with a physician who
will determine if a prescription is
appropriate offer about only a
prescribed three but minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply
co-op several folding into the report
safety for mission remember that's for
hems calm saturated they actually made
me read that a disclaimer so I try to do
that on TV where they go but they do but
I think you could read it you could hear
it yeah I could yeah you could
understand everything I said
so that's it guys cool I'm close to
being in a trough bro and heavy
breathing ran from the bathroom what
else I guess we're done right we did it
were here we talked on are we in war you
want to talk about that I was just
asking questions
oh yeah I don't think so more still hi
actually you know I haven't met this dog
before oh oh Fredo potato he's such a
sweetheart
Holy Smoke no sweet you are so cute how
old is this dog I think he's just about
a year a year although small forever huh
oh yeah he's from yeah we got a puppy
he's probably smells it on me oh she's
cold
her name is nur fee and it's like I have
immediately become a complete softy I
was a real hard-ass before I got this
dog get this I'm like talking to it all
day
uh-huh work from home so I do is talk to
this dog hey first dog I had a dog
growing up but I had one too but no
count because your parents walk it like
now I gotta make sure this thing doesn't
poop inside but the party train
there still are yeah five months you
said five months in five and a half
she's the cutest thing when she's about
I would say two is when they're fully
marinated yeah but I love my dogs like
old shredder shredder about just so he's
over to know so that that seems to be
like everybody gets another dog when how
old was a clown like when you got Sunday
she was I want to say three yeah there's
like a that period is like the prom
because we just like had no time to
focus on shredder anymore mm-hmm spoiled
and he was our only focus basically
buddy and shredder the shredder like
help so sure train like the other older
dogs with obedience a little bit
opposite really
sunday was the Dom yeah really immunity
just walked into the house ran the
energy ran the [ __ ] show yeah so yeah
I'm daddy now yeah yeah and it kind of
sucks
it takes you for walks pretty much now
we were feel bad for shredder if he got
Batum cooked yeah yeah yeah but he isn't
he's alphas [ __ ] good good you know what
shredders off let's talk about ear or
less there's so much happened since
we've been gone as anything less let's
head them off anything fine reaching for
died here go for it that happened in the
last month no but yeah that happened oh
my god oh my god damn sense of time is
always well there's all kinds of now
let's talk about Epstein there's been
updating boy 60 minutes did a really
interesting story on you guys think he
did it
no you think he did it
[Laughter]
I'm a critic of Michael Jackson I think
he's a filthy pedo and I get a lot of
[ __ ] when I say that Michael Jackson's a
filthy
a predatory pedophile or do you get [ __ ]
like because people think he's Ennis and
they've proven it no there's plenty of
proof but what I will say about its kind
of tough what I will say about Michael
Jackson is that if he wasn't a famous
pop star people like there's as much
evidence against him as there is against
Epstein and we're like oh heck I [ __ ]
kids but Michael Jackson he gets that
doubt cuz he wrote thriller even though
thrill is just about telling everyone
just for some reason now everyone's
ready to like just write r.kelly
do you think Michael Jackson would be in
jail right now if he hadn't taken the
the sleepy pills well I don't that's a
fascinating question where would he be
right because we're holding old [ __ ] up
like he'd be in deep [ __ ] do you think
he'd be on Twitter like no it's okay you
could sleep in bed with boys how would
he be yeah I don't think he'd be on
Twitter but I don't think he'll be in
jail no he does well he already went
throughout him who's the first person to
go throw that fit in court you know 9
2010 right right yeah no I remember you
know I'm a Michael Jackson fan of his
music sure not a man of his pedophilia
obviously yeah but but what if that's
what may be good it's quite possible
what if it was fueled by like the
innocence of children look at it in a
new light I suppose like when you listen
to leave me alone is it just did you
guys watch the leaving Neverland
documentary so we started it um and I
think the Aaron was the one that kind of
made us turn off she was like I already
know how this goes I don't want to what
so we never finished it yeah it's a
pretty dark day you know I think I think
that I love I loved it I could only
stand listening to dudes talking about
Michael Jackson staring at their boy
bottles for like 30 seconds before I
have to turn it off it's your max yeah I
feel 30 good seconds good seconds and
then it's off good good seconds and then
it's back to TLC
and then it's back different that dudes
in trouble yeah no I do I thought it was
very compelling I don't give another
shot what were we talking about we're
talking so Epstein so here I was
watching on 60 minutes let me find my my
notes here that I took on this topic
have no names by the way never know oh I
can give you a solid one wool I know I
went straight can we show ya I'm sorry
I'm like sneaking like you could show so
sneaky Anna Ackroyd's crystal school
vodka which honestly has the coolest
case as you know as everyone in the
world knows what is that one I thought
it would be come on bought that for us
crystal had Aurora Lucy and don't think
it's it like reflects light Chisholm no
I didn't know I did that some kind of
rap on it
do you anyone want to step of this now
okay I can't do it I just want I just
want to try I've never tried always been
assassinated only 70 bucks
I said sleary hey a chair is common
etiquette big money Cheers you know I've
heard there was a study recently that
says all vodka regardless of grade and
price is exactly the same I just agree
this is really smooth and I've had not
smooth vodka it's all identical you
cannot have different grades of vodka by
the very nature of the alcohol I think
that's like you know go to the liquor
store next time you buy a bottle of
vodka that you like by the really shitty
bankers Club just as long as they're the
same scores okay now sponsor well Dan do
we have do we have vodka here I'll do a
taste test do we have some shitty vodka
in the kitchen let me check some same
temperature today I feel like
temperature is the biggest fact oh yeah
yeah an expectation
yes I will say like stuff like Grey
Goose and I don't know I know but like
yeah Grey Goose tastes different tastes
better like maybe maybe tasting they
filter it Meyer I don't know that is
good stuff well that one's for orange
flavor yeah [ __ ] that's you think you
better than you think you can tell the
difference compare a bet that's better
okay let's let if your little city dream
uh holding any water there you go
perfect good idea here out let me let me
hook you up and by the way I did buy
Jack a new corkscrew yes break he went
on and are you buddy not cheap it was
like you get to keep that one call it a
cheap piece of [ __ ] you get to keep that
one but it was like I think you should
yeah you bought all yeah uber driver
homes gonna love this
oh what's going on there oh this looks
[ __ ] cheap but that's definitely poor
that out Burnett out into my see this is
quite Drupal distilled so maybe it's
good then I don't know I think that
should zone Lee trip so can you take
shitty vodka and just run it through a
Brita Yetzirah close and you're Puff
Daddy
I always pour Lacroix in it anyway so
anyway in sixty minutes they go through
Epstein cell they charted out they talk
about the schedule of the guards yeah
and they talked to the Epstein's brother
got an independent autopsy on his body
now all all of the tapes are destroyed
every stare was a tape of the hallway
there was a tape of his cell that's
they're all gone it's very suspect
what the hell and then the other thing
is that you actually show his cadaver
and you can see when you go in his room
there's a pile of sheets there was like
so many doesn't it's so weird and the
guy was on suicide watch he was removed
from suicide already like soul like
self-inflicted injuries he he tried to
commit suicide and failed
put him on suicide watch trying a week
later some doc was like I he's fine and
they knew them all and then when the the
thing he apparently hung himself with
was like a super thin cut of orange
jumper and there was no blood or or
anything on it but his neck was super
like bruised like bloody so the the
fibers are that strong in an orange
jumpsuit or the prison does that really
make sense because like when you see the
bruise it looks like
think that like a wire would do like
this right that's what he said yeah and
there is like blood and supposedly he
just used like this piece of fabric and
that doesn't really make any no
detective and so he's a tall guy like
six foot or more mm and he hung himself
from like less than five feet up yeah so
we had to like just willfully you know
hang himself while he could stand it
doesn't really sound austere II I have
seen on Twitter do you guys follow John
McAfee on Twitter by any chance
I mean I'm aware interesting Twitter
follow that dude is II's either out of
his mind or he's on another plane of
knowledge but he has some funny [ __ ]
that he says but he was also like he's
into this epstein thing he's like given
his take on it and he's pointing out
that like Epstein had this cellmate
which by the way dan if you can find it
they talk about that and stick his [ __ ]
you talk about the cop yeah they talks
to his jack yeah they talked about that
in 69 looks like he could have strangled
it with like a piece of floss it was
this crazy cop who was like murdered
yeah ordered people had nothing to lose
and was his cellmate and they were
thinking like well you know they let
they got him out of the cell and then at
some point that was just to make it look
like Epstein was alone and at some point
they let him back into so yeah they said
he was apparently alone in a Cell when
he died but all the security footage is
disappeared not any event the crazy
thing is that on the independent autopsy
the guy who did it said so there's like
three bones at your neck and all three
of them were broken he says usually from
hanging you'll see one it's normal to
see one rarely to never all three that
only happens he's seen in his experience
from strangulation God show and let's be
[ __ ] real that somebody murdered him
yeah I mean like what are we even
debating
even 60 minutes was trying to just
remain credible as possible but they're
like this guy [ __ ] this guy yeah they
keep like turning the camera come on Jim
Halpert come on
but actually the guards are being
investigated by the FBI so the FBI's
involved yeah it's the guards fault are
we everybody ever gonna find out they
falsified the records so there'll be the
fall guys hey if you don't falsify these
records
we're gonna [ __ ] kill you in your
entire family oh [ __ ] okay and then
they're going okay I guess records yeah
good Christian I mean they're you know
prison guards who so who killed him I
mean there are so many people that stood
to benefit from him dying we all Prince
Andrew yeah Prince Andrew that's yeah
Andrew I mean he already got dragged
pretty good though no no no what's it
say yeah he did interviews or no maybe
was an English press but I think um I
don't know there could be so many so
many people all rich yeah just a lot of
men amusing on this plane Ricky Gervais
said the best joke at the Golden Globes
he go I thought you can see he killed
him yeah
Ricky's your face killed him with that
joke he said what'd he say it was a joke
II loved your friend of his but what was
the leader yeah he was like something
didn't hang itself or but didn't kill
itself or something like that that's
right yes yes everyone got it was like
oh he's like no yeah I think he doesn't
he doesn't kill himself at the end of
the movie there's a movie about suicides
like he doesn't kill himself in his
movie you know what else didn't kill
himself right that's right oh come on I
know you're his friend that's true that
was a sick how legendary was that whole
opening that he ballsy so yeah Aaron has
a theory that like he's just he's made
Ricky's just made so much goddamn money
that it's basically [ __ ] you money and
he's like I'm gonna stop this is like
the last time well I was I was a little
joke last time but like when you've made
it as far as he has he don't have to
rely on Hollywood ever again I feel like
that's kind of where he's at but it's
pretty amazing the way he's doing it
because he's still managing to actually
do stuff like he's and he's got it shows
and he's still yeah and the BBC - yeah
he works for in England a lot so there's
definitely something to it we're like a
lot of people a lot of famous people or
people who are public have to pander to
people who are easily offended but if
you've never even had them to begin with
when they get offended you're like well
I didn't I didn't lose you right you're
just someone who's mad who doesn't like
me already and then the people who still
like him are like well yeah I know he's
an [ __ ] but he's funny
yeah and that's sort of like we're you
that's the sweet spot when you can just
be super offensive and you don't have to
worry about anyone being like I thought
you were different right never happens
yeah that's I think he's trying to get
fired and he's been trying to do that
for five years it was first time I mean
his fifth time yeah he can say no who's
fantastic no but I he's enjoying it if
you fall on Twitter he's like it's like
he never had any of these people in his
corner at all and it's just it's sort of
like Dave Chapelle like he can say these
really offensive things but he was never
pretending that he was anything yeah you
know pandering to the people who he's
offended mmm they were gone always if
they ever liked them it was like not
because he wanted them to alright they
joke about and like you see Tim Apple in
the crowd the CEO of Apple because they
made a streaming network on Apple sound
like Trump so and I'm when I saw him I
was like [ __ ] this Deeb like [ __ ] you
trying to you he wants to have his kid
he's like the cool guy and everyone's
gotta suck his dick because he's got the
streaming platform that everyone wants
to be on like he's getting jet he's
paying Jennifer Aniston like 2 million
per episode to be in this stupid little
[ __ ] drama and he's a an apple is
[ __ ] evil [ __ ] company and he and
I think he did a great thing and I think
he made a great joke ELA when he says
that if Isis made a streaming service
you'd all be calling your agent would it
was a great but have you so speaking of
Apple TV Plus or whatever it is have you
have you guys watched any of the shows
on there because we did we actually
finished the morning show though
Jennifer Aniston I actually heard it's
good actually good I gotta like it it's
it's free and like yeah like I can see
many episodes are there 8 to 10 that
that hole
20 million yeah oh yeah she's not
hurting and then servant is like the M
night Shyamalan show yeah week that
weren't that yeah we just came out last
night said that's gotta suck right
here's deal I don't want without any
spoilers amazing premise I thought it
was going to be a one season like
self-contained story kind of ends on a
bit of a cliffhanger and M night has
come out and said yeah I wanna do six
seasons of the show so I'm a little
pissed I'm kind of like yeah [ __ ] that
that's a lot of time to [ __ ] it up it's
a lot yeah he'll find a way but it's
like it would have been such a great
self-contained one season horror yeah
like like atmosphere sucks I have no
faith left in that clown no he's good
he's in the show like he directed one or
two episodes of the show and it's good
but I really hate the whole ending it on
a cliffhanger when it could have been
this whole it could've been one story a
sham Lana hasn't been paid in a minute
he's got he's been making a ton of ass
flops hasn't he I'm trying to think what
split was good that's it that's it split
I like to split yes but it was his
script of his land he wasn't he wrote
that character into the original
breakable unbreakable and then cut it
out weight split oh like maybe he does
still suck
he's like using his old [ __ ] maybe he if
he has more scripts in that desk he
needs to pull them out maybe he's got a
story now they were one of them's a good
writer yeah and that one's died like
2008 yeah
mandalorian amazing mm-hmm I don't like
halfway through that show but I need I
need to finish that guy enjoy it
baby Yoda like that may be uh a genius
what a genius move it really is like
what it was a gamble to me so you know
it's Bo des but like it well off in
spades yeah there's like no person that
could look at it and not love it yes no
matter like gender age I love the way
that everything about it yeah yeah
there's a bill burr episode that I don't
know if you guys have seen yet where he
interacts with babe oh yes that was
actually one of my favorite yeah yeah
it's like it was a five or six I was not
expecting much from Bill burr I have to
say but you didn't really well he pops
up in the craziest things yeah it was
just like his IMDB the favorite episode
he was in Britain yeah yeah he's great
in that he wasn't he in I don't know I'm
not gonna go too deep into his IMDB cuz
I can't remember that [ __ ] but he's like
he pops up in something you're like what
right this guy's agent well they
actually wanted him they just wrote to
him Wow did he tell us that yeah I don't
remember yeah he's not even like s hours
you know fanatic and I knew it was funny
for him he was talking about out like
his character sang things that you only
hear in the Star Wars universe I was
like oh my god he was definitely given
people [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] is that
the only thing he knows is the Jar Jar
reference I know that um Mandalorian is
good Dracula on Netflix loved it oh I
haven't yeah things about that so I'm a
bit more hesitant I'm on the mixer
you're on the mix I know you wanna I
don't think it's stuck the landing but
oh okay so there's Buster phobic for me
just the first step like your babies
like suck and displace an awful I say
it's all bottle oh no um I will say
about Dracula it's the same guys who
made Sherlock would you like well my
favorite shows what they notoriously
[ __ ] up the ending of that to read
this had the worst ending I mean the
ending was so cool yeah yeah I was
frozen I did what I was there for the
ride but yeah when I got there it was
closed
yeah is this similar and Sherlock in
that it's three okay and that's the time
sink
cuz the thing was like I was like 80%
through episode three and I was like oh
there has to be another yeah right I was
like cool awesome then you remember it's
the Sherlock guys and you're like nope
they shot me I'm at three [ __ ] movies
and then it's over and that's over for
like four years
but I'm Joyce arise fantastic though
yeah the riot was a good ride but the
ending just know that you're not gonna
be happy with I don't know more than
watch it and you were spooked it doesn't
happen to me very frequently that I
can't watch something you got spooked
not just pool
it was like annoying me I couldn't was
the claustrophobia yeah okay yeah that's
what it was I was claustrophobic was
spooky tight spaces you're in the top
and a castle oh speaking of shows that
did the one and done watchman
watch watch watch me I was watch manic I
loved also and it's done it up and the
ending was um was pretty good career how
great yeah show itself was I love it
when they do that when they're like nope
that was it
that all you get we are bringing it back
I was reading about that the guy who
made it they're like they wanted him for
season two yeah and he's like I don't
have a story to tell for season two so
I'm not gonna do it I was like yeah yeah
what a novel concept you may actually
not understand it and so I stopped
watching but I see how much everyone
loved it that I kind of feel like I
think you forced yourself for two or
three apps then you'll get into it I
will say like the best episodes are kind
of like past the midway point that's
when I gots like five six yeah ooh yes
ooh that Lindelof guy does this thing
where he spends so much time in the
beginning it doesn't he did with lost
yeah did it with the leftovers with a
creator and he just like spends it's
like when you're cooking and you got to
chop all your vegetables your meson plas
yeah you got to get everything on the
cutting board and then you start cooking
and you're throwing the onions in it
boom here's a [ __ ] Carl everything's
already chopped oh there we go
bop bop and that's like the midway point
of the season yes is when everything
starts actually getting cooked
everything else shopping and measuring
things and so payout team edible and I
will say I feel like I got a little bit
more out of the show because I had read
the the Watchmen graphic novel
beforehand I don't know if I would have
gotten as much I'll just give you some
context that will help you kind of
yeah and then there was a lot of big
black [ __ ] in it too we had a lot of big
black [ __ ] in a good man like that guy
was standing around some I don't think
it was quite as gratuity no there was
like a full big black [ __ ] like several
times well well yeah but that's like
against the norm like we're so used to
seeing full frontal on the female side
like game with I actually have a problem
with that like why hmm well you got a
yearns for a tree a guy you only see but
right well [ __ ] is what we veg on so
here's the thing if I can play devil no
you cannot on this because tits are not
as vulgar as vagina says who will go and
make it woman oh you think tits are
vulgar as vagina it's not as vulgar but
it's still and naked like well I'm just
I'm explaining what not walking with my
tits out on the street is I think the TV
you know the producers or the whatever
there is no explaining anything
I'm telling you [ __ ] is more vulgar than
tits and vaginas equally as vulgar as a
[ __ ] you've just been programmed to feel
that way yes
I'm not saying it's right I'm just
saying that's how they view it and the
thing is like when you see a bush you
just see a bunch of hair like if you saw
a shaved bush on TV and you saw
everything like the cut you see the [ __ ]
and the balls and everything actually a
lot of movies worse to wear a merkin now
that's well over the act yeah you could
see everything yeah there were a lot
there was a lot of full frontal yeah
nudity for women yeah and occasionally
God but they had bush covering the
details like if I had a giant Bush
covering my [ __ ] you could show my bush
you can see any dick
did you see dick and Game of Thrones the
little tiny oh there was there was there
was dick EULA whose dick juicy I'm
trying to remember too so I'm not just
like but that was like the Theon on
Theon stack yeah Wow yeah okay that's
not the same wait why
Oh cuz oh you're you're sick you're sick
because it's like literally severed no
but they no no I'm not only showed his
car yeah they do a sex scene what's not
the same you know because I thought
isn't he
that gets his dick yeah but they didn't
I was like in that context no they each
others severed penis he definitely
showed [ __ ] but not as much as awesome
and you were you gotta watch off that
dude dick heaven my god we got Chris
Meloni Pete I feel like everyone in
jails [ __ ] guy who's doing everything
hates him and he was in every HBO shows
yeah JK Simmons dick right we got I feel
like everybody in Oz has a huge [ __ ]
yeah probably everyone in jail has a
huge [ __ ] yeah they do that to you when
you get in I feel like if you see dick
in jail its fat yeah you got a pump you
know you guys our with everybody else
you'd only be the guy with the smallest
dick in prison you just don't make it
you don't match it up every time but I
guess this is elope I feel like um you
know mr. dr. Manhattan you got to see
the deck so they did it justice cuz he's
all he's this blue guys always naked and
that's a big out clothing in the movie
they famously put underwear on him we're
in the comic book sacrilege I disagree
infamously put underwear no in the movie
they let it hang in the movie for a few
shots I remember really arms yet the
trailers they put underwear on him in
the actual movie the actual people are
upset about the [ __ ] they weren't there
was a lot of outrage like no and it's
like that's because we don't see a lot
of [ __ ] in in film and television so
obviously those shots stood out he's
also got a big one I got yes he's dr.
Manhattan himself together from Adams
why would he give himself a baby dick I
remember the outrage in 2009 people who
like wool whose [ __ ] should look every
shot and it's like yeah you're just like
it was too sexy no some underwear on
this ones I'm having oh [ __ ] please one
out in the theater come on bring my kid
to this movie could squeeze one out next
to my kid man I saw a movie in the
theaters in Prague because I was
traveling abroad
but my cell you were just seeing dick on
the way to the theater absolutely yeah
everybody's naked yeah free free country
man yeah
no it's not good you guys remember that
scene in Washington where the FBI lady
pulled out that huge blue dildo it's a
great little touch because we like still
remembers but it was her dealings with
dr. Manhattan and I saw that dick was
like multiple pieces one of those crazy
we had to like connect the balls people
watching at home were like I haven't
seen it anyway what else we got um I had
a viral moment during the break you had
a viral moment yeah we say that why do
we save our moment it's references like
an epic a moment the politicians running
for oh yeah they kept saying they needed
a viral moment which like you know on
the debates they're all trying to create
a viral yeah yeah yeah yeah which is so
sad they just catch the flu that's a
viral mohel a viral I saw this yeah rice
comes very scum you know every time I
see rice go grow tweet something like
somewhat clever he goes I hate when
people say it's a quarter till 6:00
[ __ ] just say it's fine just I'm do
guys yell stupid and so you copy it and
you paste it and you see that it's been
tweeted before almost identical and I
found this tweet from November and you
know he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] he could
have at least changed it a little bit
but it kept the same like 575 just don't
bleed anything if you don't have
anything to say don't steal well you
know all this all these tweets are
stolen oh he did and y'all stupid
yeah but ya know he put his own twist on
it he said y'all and said a little
stupid anyway I said here's the tweet he
stole I actually done that a couple
times before cuz I don't know yeah call
him out and anyway he DM me and he goes
yeah [ __ ] you and your [ __ ] like that's
creepy dude but he made it that's
[ __ ] creepy I gave you a little cute
little didn't like any blocky blocked
you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's great I was like
what yeah epic gamer move dude a bit
speaking of the flu has that guy cleared
his sinuses out yet wait what do you
mean dude sounds like he's always got
[ __ ] cotton balls up his nose yeah
president no thank you everybody for
acknowledging my viral moment I wish you
would does anyone have anything to say
to celebrate my viral moment yeah you
made it congratulations from eula Jack
you made it you [ __ ] made it
Eric do you have any comments uh yeah go
ahead
no is it just yeah yeah I do that's not
a comment that's knowledge meant that
you have a column here's a question I
can't it be both why do people think
they can get away with stealing tweets
when there is when the Internet is
written in ink and you can't dispute it
you can't be like well no no I had the
same joke it's like no it's verbatim
look at how hey don't really doesn't
care
not affair Twitter is kind of a
wasteland
just doesn't care like if you think
about like high school it's sort of the
same thing that goes on there really is
that Joker like the guy like whispers a
joke to you and then you say it out loud
and the class laughs yes it's like very
much like that right where that's a
beautiful analogy
let me just [ __ ] copy and paste the
Joker he stole had 65,000 lines
oh well that's even I feel like he has a
folder on his desktop called stolen
tweets totally and he waits a month or
two months in that case he just and then
he blocked it out it's a whole [ __ ]
that's all right how [ __ ] Sorry mate
yeah oh yeah those guys goddamn worst
actually got pretty good Wow they turn
their [ __ ] private they got they got
jack if the rebrand now they got [ __ ]
by big blue [ __ ] it is nice to see that
happen can I find that dildo well with
race kind it doesn't matter cuz
like appeal to a bunch of teenagers like
hey yeah stop listening to this rapper
he steals tweets like okay whatever
boomer they're still going like crazy
[ __ ] Terry wait wait
they're still literally screenshotting
other people's twisting out right there
and there they got a huge promotion so
their videos have a lot of you right
right wait there only awesome that's
really cool Wow you're right
I think the thing is that Instagram
being owned by Facebook is they
literally only care about engagement
they don't they have no Mark Zuckerberg
is he's just like a evil dude or maybe
he's just like super autistic I think
he's just a robot I don't know he's had
no wave no I think he's just he just
goes where the money is and that becomes
evil yeah because he has such influence
like there's a reason he's like bigger
than anything right I think he knows he
[ __ ] up and he's like I'm out down
baby like Homer Simpson I feel like an
excuse in the beginning but once you
have such influence but what if you have
like mega autism I don't think he does I
think he has mega I think he's smarter
to know he's doing and yeah yeah mixed
with mega autism he really wants to like
make his mark on the world and it's good
pun by the way it wants to make his
[ __ ] in the word you must make his
goal he once he wants to suck the souls
out of everyone hmm but he I think he
wants to like go down and he was the the
history books to be kind to him when we
think about him he doesn't wanna get
murdered he's gonna get that runs you
know the guy must Google his name or at
least have people who google it for him
and they go mark it's not looking good
look everyone thinks you're a [ __ ]
weirdo yeah or worse that that
barbecuing video you did what the hell
was that I mom mom meet Jeff cards
I'm all like making fun of his haircut
is like a mainstream joke now yeah whoa
what is that a tude in general like
people got so tired of making fun of the
way that he is that they're like what
about that haircut yeah porn into that
yet you know hmm
yeah this is getting very I'm just gonna
let this get more awkward this as
everyone waits for me to say something I
forgot
mmm it'll come to you the sock Oh can
meets we weren't you gonna like oh yeah
which one is better
yeah yes I saw I poured you wanna do it
blind yeah I do want to do a blind tell
me which is which well you're doing well
so yeah I'll taste I'll just take a
taste okay so I'll tell you right now
this is this is the crystal and this is
the Burnett so that's the Burnett
crystal do you do the shitty one first
or the good one first wait is everyone
needs to be blind and only you know so
so Neela you need to somehow
why are you dong kyun you come in come
here and pour some blind shots yeah or
not Ian Zak sorry if you close your eyes
I will either switch them up or double
switch them up so they're not stuff but
you don't know what we should all do it
at once because we can't milk it that
long people are gonna wait for that
thank you Dad just do three already know
like so all you got to do is like
literally hold them and then like maybe
put them on you're like can you find out
how much which one is which okay that is
Burnett that's skull okay and what's the
price point on Burnett can you look that
up want to make sure it sort of shitty
but Matt I mean well we want to all
three at once go ahead take your time
man vodka I mean I could just take a
squid guy eat the Bob seven Wow seven
bucks for that thing what is come from
what Bugan brought this to the office
no bro that's quadruple distilled that
was that was definitely the the dentist
sticker brought that here for you guys
the finest that's the cheapest [ __ ] ever
bro I think we purposely bought the
cheapest vodka first yeah we bought that
okay but we should do it with the we
should do with Gregor let's do 3 3 3 go
ahead Dan oh boy we're getting to the
end of the show I'll get trashed I want
to know
check ok what else we got we got us ok
so everyone knows Australia's on fire
yeah but did you know that through Teddy
fresh we raised fifty thousand seven
hundred and three dollars hey
congratulations you got yourself on the
back let me show you we made I actually
thought that we would promote day two on
the show this shirts actually amazing I
saw that shirt online I looked know our
sky save the koalas half goes to the
Koala hospital they're called the Koala
hospital because there's no they're the
only one have they been sending you like
pictures of koalas and stuff like no I'm
you could at least get some pictures and
then the Rural Fire Service you know how
it is so but that but that was amazing
well done so that was Eli's design thank
you everybody go ahead and page work you
guys you guys have done more for the
world in that moment than I think I've
ever done in my entire life well I'll
take that yeah I did save a koala but I
was the one in danger so we'll do one at
a time okay okay so the whole thing I
mean everyone I will so wait Mel it does
it smell different vodka okay okay
alright that's the bad one hmm
they're all the best okay okay I'm sorry
it tastes pretty bad right I mean Oh
here's the deal Oh God
I can't believe you got it took the
whole thing maybe she could trash after
this oh I shouldn't get trashed not I
was gonna invite you guys over all right
you could come over to our house I'm not
saying no to that oh but but you're
doing a show you don't me scream the
n-word
well that's Jack's job right we all know
that well we're on break Jack was like I
was like I hold him back he was ready to
fight
Ian about it Ian was like hey and then
you start saying things about kpop that
I was like you can't take some things
back the worst you were like I'm just
kidding I would never he was always very
much okay so all right so yeah keep that
taste fresh in your mind okay cheers
Cheers
how do I smell it don't but the case in
point it all smells the same this is I'm
gonna rank this lower than the one we
just did you know what the problem is is
that you hate vodka the more you drink
it to me it tastes the same not for you
to drink that yeah really
yeah I think it's a little lower because
it's just like sharper okay and if you
look good let me thank my notes cuz I
don't have not gone in that one second
one was lower yeah I think I think the
first one was the skull yeah that one
was the cheap [ __ ] and this next one is
about to blow our [ __ ] that's my guess
and I didn't even try wait what was your
guess did you smell it school no just
based on the reactions here oh so we're
gonna be like but actually I wasn't I
wasn't bringing up possibilities on fire
to Pat myself on the back should I
wanted to why did but um what I really
wanted to say is that a lot of people
have been donating a lot of money
Metallica donated 750 dr. Chris 750
thousand obviously Metallica yeah the
band the band Chris Hemsworth Thor
donated a million DiCaprio donated three
million
Kylie Jenner DiCaprio the cop Leonardo
nice
Kylie Jenner 1 million yuan Elton John 1
million Ethan and Uwe Klein of Teddy
fresh fifty thousand seven
but then here's where my question comes
in now I'm not usually someone money is
money donation is a donation it's all
good but what do you make of Jeff Bezos
donating $690,000 a lot of people made
the comparison of like that's literally
equivalent of a middle-class person
donating I don't know $69 I think no
less less yeah I think it was like that
was the argument I think it was you
should have made that if he makes that
in six minutes yeah yeah don't ya don't
like that little he makes that in six
minutes
love it love it that's have lots of
rocket ships I needed to shoot also it's
a [ __ ] move when you're like oh I was
wondering what's with the weird number
so it's a million Australian dollars
that's why it's weird that's why it's so
like you're right he knows what a dollar
if you saving himself money
yeah Australian people buy from Amazon
yeah cheers Cheers
all right yes James my cheese I think I
know it all tastes the same it really
wasn't me wrong I'm gonna say one was
the best and then maybe two was the
worst and three was the middle be
awesome if Dan if they were all the
worst like one all right I'll put myself
out in the locker okay once it's cool
who is the Burnet and really improve
your way that's what I feel like I've
already proved my point
yeah if these were all different vodkas
the second one tasted worse okay but
okay the third so my guess was the first
one was the worst Burnet two was scull
three was the nice [ __ ] Vegas I guess it
was oh okay
so go ahead damn what what was it yeah
I'm like Jack got it right wait what was
what was it what the same the the first
one was the Cisco the second one was my
cheap [ __ ] yeah and then the third one
was the greatest Wow but that said we
still did call it I feel like you got
what they mean they don't taste the same
they don't yeah oh yeah we got yes we
were able to discern what was what I
don't know therefore you guys got lucky
you wrong very mad hos mad
I mean I got I got the nice one right -
but granted I mean they they both
viscerally recoiled as soon as they
tasted that Burnett it seemed it was
pretty obvious I guess the lesson here
the $7 vodka might taste like yes but
like the I mean you get to the higher
class vodkas right yeah I think there's
a there's there's the crappy [ __ ] and
then yeah $20 enough it's probably all
the same what I love is the vodkas that
like they don't know how to make
themselves seem better so they put
gluten-free on the label made of me I
mean what's [ __ ] potato nah by the
very nature of it well I mean not in the
juice that you squeeze out of it I don't
know how vodkas made they squeeze the
juice out of datas yeah well they leave
all the gluten behind this is a scumbag
anyone want to add anything to that I do
actually
only because it's somewhat relevant so
the reason I have this hideous goddamn
creepy uncle pedo stache right now is
because last week we did a little
charity livestream on twitch for oh yeah
Rob yeah raise money for meds we did
just because we felt like we had to do
something wrong you're saying cuz
because we have viewers in Australia and
we wanted to like you know for each
other so this was one of the you know
how when you do a donation oh yeah
charity think you have like goals you
know if you varies a hundred dollars
will do this if you raise $5,000 will do
that this was some one of those tears
like I will shave my beard so how long
you gotta keep it I think a month you
raise quite a bit you raise 50,000 right
we raised $50,000 a lien dollars which i
think translates to like maybe 36 that's
American like that saved a lot of koalas
I hope so thank you thank you thank you
thank you but I just want to say there's
a reason this exists and it's not
because I think it's a fashionable thing
I didn't think now think it looks bad
would never think that I do you clean it
up a little
well you got like whiskers going over
your lip I would recommend it oh yeah
this is rough yeah I got a guy yeah
now just got a trimmer for Christmas
Neela thanks my tip he doesn't want to
yeah I know what are you just trying to
make him feel bad well he's gotta wear
it it's a charity I'm just being honest
what okay what else do you want to say
about it I think like a connection with
creepy guys with mustache your
connection or like in my head yeah yeah
gotcha
it translates a little bit creepy I had
a mustache for a little bit yeah I mean
mustaches are always creepy but do you
make that you connection with my dad no
it's not you dad cuz he is a mustache
well dad's with mustache is not the only
er I'm a dad with I can be down with
mustache it should be a dad with a
mustache I kind of want to be in the bus
- bad dude if you don't do that I'm
gonna take a koala out I'm flying down
straight I'm taking a koala out you get
a mustache those you know Arlo [ __ ]
man they're so slow the fire just burned
them alive
kind of like sloths honestly they're so
slow and cute and they're like oh we
can't escape the fire so fast they're
slow but they're like they're cute
looking but they are kind of vicious
they are open aware of them and like
yeah that's what I learn I mean that's
what I've been told like they're
actually kind of like hostile and good
cigarettes no walking I'm smoking Jules
baby sorry
no no no no let's talk Jules no koalas
are they're dangerous they're cut from
what I heard and Chris wrong in a crowd
I'm sorry I don't mean to like speak out
of turn but that's what I've heard
there's like don't don't go up to a
koala should I feel bad or no well that
kind of makes sense if it's a wild koala
and what else are you what other wild am
looking at Farpoint you know it should
that should they perish or should I feel
bad enough left I'm saying like like
they're they look cute but they're
actually I if he looking hug Alfredo
then then he's severe to all I think all
such a sweetie pie how old is Alfredo
he's like a year he's a little puppet
you know puppetry you know
okay so Australia is on fire koalas are
dying Jeff Bezos is a douche the Prime
Minister's a douche of Australia that
guy's a real [ __ ] do she's like a
climate change
growing a [ __ ] tantrum because he had
to come back from his Hawaii vacation
yeah deal with his entire country being
on fire I go I saw him doing it every
he's like I made a promise to my son but
sometimes you need to compromise and I
realized Oh what is your oh yeah what I
hear I was like wow everyone mean my
entire country's on I'm giving him a
pompous British accent because he
doesn't deserve an Australian one and
while that accents way are giving them
Prince Andrew's accent there's been some
great videos of like people trying to
shake his hand actually here I have it
here oh no you take their hand and
they're like refuse they'll see shot oh
thank you firefighters actually and
they're like I don't want to say this is
a clip from the brush fire showing you
how fat this one shocked the hell out of
me you know there's a strong gust of
wind you can see how fast the fryer is
capable of spreading here it seems like
it's it's pretty far away at that point
what well you look at the ground
right oh he blames on the ground really
turns around again it's like so hot at
the [ __ ] floors on fire so that's
what's going on in Australia and I've
seen people try to defend the fires to
saying like no this is natural this is
what happens
really oh because their climate change
deniers um that might be part of it they
always go to the most ridiculous like
dude the earth in lengths they go it's
like no no no this is all natural
bro the earth froze over entirely for
like a hundred thousand years it's all
good the Prime Minister's a climate
change denier university is yeah yeah
yes it turns out that people just admit
it just admit it
yeah [ __ ] happening we have terabytes
of scientific it's not a political thing
it's [ __ ] Han right right why yes I
don't understand why it's being
politicized when it's like how like why
are we arguing this is because oil
but he's more often than not our that's
conservative
that's and they're like well we could we
could do something about that
I think they tap into this same lizard
brain of the anti-vaccine and so
distrustful of government that you can
pretty much convince them of anything so
you go oh well climate changes of
Chinese hoaxes and Al Gore hoax to get
you to the conspiracy theories aren't
crazy like to get you to buy to spend
money to on [ __ ] you know it's like what
like that the argument doesn't hold
water when you're like okay let's say
climate change is fake and that you're
just making the air cleaner that's not
all that already is not a noble enough
objective like what like what is the con
what are the cons of that well it's like
cigarette smokers who are like no I'm
not gonna get lung cancer it's the same
mentality it's like whatever you know
the world's not gonna be fine the
drinkers are fine I'm gonna get killed
by a bus you know bus get hit me
tomorrow yeah yeah this is just climate
change in areas who are like they don't
want to think about their kids are gonna
be [ __ ]
yeah the kids are [ __ ] yeah they're
smoking while pregnant yeah right I'm
gonna do whatever the kids not gonna
come out with like anything wrong with
actually there was people in his
government there was people in his
government those chilling prime minister
who were warning him for years that
there was this brush fire disaster
brewing cuz huh everything was super dry
and they knew there was this enormous
fire threat and he wasn't acting to
clear brush and prevent this Wow so he's
been ignoring the issue for for Solars
know how long has he been the the Prime
Minister man yeah dan dan yeah yeah
Dantonio you're not familiar with the
Australian government well it says now
the the amount of animals that diet is
up to 800 million that's [ __ ] I heard a
billion and the ones that did sir
we're gonna face starvation so how many
people are on the planet
Billy zoomed office in August of 2018
you're not gonna do the math for us then
dad a year for month I'll take it thanks
Dan she was at least warned about these
this upcoming disaster I saw that
they're dropping carrots and [ __ ] from
airplanes over the forest to feed these
poor little critters there's like this
footage of them just walking through the
areas that were broke and there's just
so many just dead animals
I saw one where a koala came out all
like no probably you the carrots thing
is a little odd because it like I mean
maybe it's just because my brain is a
dark place but all I can think about is
like carrots just [ __ ] free me but
you might be on to something because
they were pretty high up let me drop
those carrots they didn't have little
prepared parachutes anyway seems a
little counter that's the next Pixar
movie you want you guys want to see
funny little clip always when my son was
teething he used to like to take the big
fat rubber end of my vibrating tooth
brush and put it in his mouth how are
you not seeing this
laughter like you're not even aware of
what you're doing man that's grand I
that I think it speaks to her innocence
more than anything else
oh she has no idea what the hell that is
that's wonderful
you know burger awaits you in paradise
remember that video we erased here it is
this showed up on the Internet
recently oh really apparently in Eastern
Europe they're giving away free
hamburgers in this mall to celebrate the
opening of a hamburger restaurant and
they made these two old [ __ ] race each
other on an escalator I can do that
these old [ __ ] are gonna tumble
to their death for a free burger they
made them do this like yeah I think it's
part of the competition so you may never
recover from this I'll tell you his
knees are shot this guy's like see a
[ __ ] right right there man this is like
this is like circus level entertainment
this is literally like Oh lowest common
denominator will show every burger by
hey free burgers out right guys don't
have an income anymore where was this
again you know like they speak Russian
Hoover over there some former Russian a
free burger yeah so an and we made a
reaction video that had the whole thing
like the more you think about it the
satiric yeah it's like oh oh girl beef
and a bun like there's it's like that
Sun right at like boring dystopia or
something right like that's that's the
perfect example so we called it a burger
away to impair dice and we erased it
because it wasn't a good video well
video on it but I just wasn't people did
not receive it well I can pull it up no
one cares I have dreams of making a
really bad you got to take this video
down yeah this podcast is gonna be
removed
it was great till the burger just lost
me oh I can't play the music but it's
playing this song oh yeah go ahead and
sing it in you know the song hit or miss
hit or miss I bet you never met so this
is the new Arby's
ads thoughts is that's an ad yeah Arby's
this is in collaboration with Arby's my
dudes
why wouldn't they hire the original girl
who did it I guess you never miss I
guess invent so they're about a year
later I guess yes girl did the original
one watches this is a totally I'm right
here yeah yeah I think she's probably
pissed and no no hate so those people in
it it's just kind of like no I do you
think that there's gonna help sell roast
beef sandwiches from Arby's with 40
sauce I think as long as you got your
name in someone's mouth you're probably
doing your job as an advertiser they
have the meats I mean you could do worse
nothing more romantic than a date at
Arby's I don't even know where an Arby's
is where we live
Arby's has to try pretty hard because I
create Rochas that's what I keep hearing
right oh my god never have I ever had
RV's Arby's can't sell you on like the
quality of their food they have to sell
you on like their ability to mean which
is already atrocious because this is an
old [ __ ] meat their meat yeah yeah we
get all of our meat for like why is
there meat glossy like in their muesli
where's that skull that skull had like a
like a sort of a chromatic light looks
like an oil spill yeah yeah I've noticed
that roast beef roast beef is has a
slick what is that I don't like that I
don't you know me for the light either
no not at all yeah it's like our bees
should advertise based on the slick enos
of their make lip this conversation
where this one I had a crazy
gender-reveal party this is great oh
[ __ ] yeah this is my King already hating
this kids already hating uh yeah your
sibling okay good long murderous oh no
daughters made enjoying that can you
take the dogs out that powders not men
speak just about kids not gonna make it
to the baby brother
alright now we've talked a lot about
mobility people being a danger to
society and none is better showcase our
would than this one here he's not down
and he is going to murder this big he's
fine don't worry
what's he yelling probably just to the
walk-in litter nation probably John yang
gang you like that yeah this is scooter
[ __ ]
do not walk a mobility scooter guy I'm
just fascinated by the let's go
that guy's got a lot of energy for
someone on a scooter
[Music]
[Laughter]
when you're that high up on a ladder
your homie should have your back those
guys those left them out yeah at that
level I mean who would have thought this
would happen - hey can you cover my
ladder in case a violent sky leg trust
go to the book I'm surprised that the
ladder guy didn't come over and like
just like kick the [ __ ] he's dead yeah I
didn't I said he was fine but I'm
kidding he died of his injuries
I hate no kidding he did he find his
shoes didn't come on yeah exactly that's
that's real lively Craig you skipped
over the Kevin Spacey videos we haven't
Spacey it's oh oh Kevin Spacey yeah of
course he had another holiday holiday
surprise I it was one of those things I
couldn't finish because of the cringe
well PLC who's bad
insane Kevin Kevin Spacey man this guy's
basically just being like yes I am a sex
criminal and I'm gonna own it and I may
or may not have killed you know those
bitter like have killed those people
besides all this committers are just
users really but one of them was cancer
which government can give you with
satellites yeah as we've proven and I
think the one of them got killed by got
hit by a car really and one of them
committed suicide what the hell but I
think I'm safe to eat that birds are
supposed to represent I think like
somewhere not say to be a victim no not
if Kevin Spacey there's really you don't
really think I was gonna miss the
opportunity to wish you a Merry
Christmas did you and I'm grateful to
have my health back this two days before
sorry Knight alive and I'd like to
invite you to join me as we walk into
2020
I want to cast my vote for more good in
this world oh yes I know what you're
thinking then he be serious if I stuck a
fire I'm dead serious and it's not that
hard trust me
the next time someone does something you
don't like you can go on the attack
but you can also hold your fire and do
the unexpected
you can kill them with kindness
by the way that dramatic world ending my
own did the [ __ ] iMovie sound clip is
really really cheesy what were they
thinking with that sound clip I don't
know okay it's going over his house on
the holidays and talking his drunk ass
into doing these [ __ ] videos
oh no camera guy hostage movie I like
it's a well shot though so somebody is I
wonder who I'm a mechanic criminais ting
video I'd like to think he uses the
accent like even when they don't record
he's still in his house of cards mode in
order to coffee he's like I'll have a
large potato would be a shame if that
coffee didn't come out right
if you forgot the whipped cream well I
can't be held responsible for my actions
I'd like to see you on a boat accused of
just groping young man
it was accused of like it was crazy not
awesome how like he's like oh I'm not
even gay and then it's like yeah i'ma
les dudes
he's like gay to get out of it well
right well yeah he came out as like a
tactic almost to let distract people
from the accusations
I feel like we're all gonna get Epstein
just by talking about it now you think
we can abstain this [ __ ] he did was so
brazen like okay so Jake erupts so Ethan
you're Jack's kid I am and in this
scenario and I'm spaghetti yeah all
right so we're talking at dinner and you
got your kid here yeah I'm just like
that's what he did yeah in front of the
parents no the parent didn't see cuz the
kid was sitting right there the kid was
like how old is the kid it was exciting
newscasters kid or wasn't age ish maybe
maybe not
like that's how you do movie sets he's
just like such a bitter all [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] really started here like
the worst part about it he's a damn good
actor I [ __ ] like I like yeah movies
he's in are still really good it just
sucks that he's also he probably would
have been a real shitty actor via those
things like he was like oh man I've
really raped a lot of people I gotta be
good at what I do is if I [ __ ] nail
Glengarry Glen Ross well yeah I mean he
did it it's funny that all this guilty
guys think they have the great idea to
do like he's him with this videos and
r.kelly with that interview with yeah
Chandru written and you yeah I don't
sweat I haven't sweat since 1982 it's
pretty crazy to think that it was all
good for these guys to just rape people
for so long I mean that's pretty that's
pretty wild the thing that they were
like you have so much to lose and you're
still raping and you're like they just
they keep trying and they get away with
it so and that so many people turned a
blind eye to it
yeah Cosby one rape in his whole life
like I raped like 53 women that's it
over deck I mean that that's a real
[ __ ] insane that's a career yeah
that's he like at a certain point he was
like well he's in the hall he's in the
he was in the hall rape Hall of Fame
matter
that's a terrible Cosby impression I
thought he might be one of the top five
rappers of all time he's got to be in
the Hall of Fame yeah at least he may be
the greatest of all there's like Roman
ghosts looking down like whoa yeah yeah
Jesus Christ this guy this guy's [ __ ]
up holy [ __ ] we would start having like
a allegation I am to be there you go so
I could just find a list you'll have
people get on that pattern that right
well I'll see you and patent that too
bad for me I mean I shouldn't be there
since the land
against you what you i mean sexual yeah
yeah when for example when you try to
have sex with me in the middle of the
night when I'm sleeping what the [ __ ]
that's messed up thank you that but in
my sleep it's weird I have this weird
thing where I like sleepwalk but
actually like it's you explain it
because you're the one who experiences
it not me he just well all of a sudden
seem like he's awake and he's trying to
have sex with me I'm not like a rapey
way but Betty's just wanna make that no
no I just I just you know try to get it
on but I don't remember it is it like
must actually I haven't done in a while
no it's like sleepwalking sleep okay you
did recently what yeah cuz I thought I
hadn't done in a long do you have to
mention because I used to have sleep
paralysis all the time I wonder if this
is like replaced it mm-hm guys what's
sex like sex it's a it's pretty dumb yes
should I buy some what we're like
Barbies they have the meats
you could probably stick your dick in a
meat Mountain sandwich and roast beef
has a striking resemblance to some
vaginas is so cute oh my dog a thing I
go my own dog a thing so Kevin Spacey is
a creepy raper Duke may be murderer me
which certainly teases that really
bright cherry on top
I love how two days before one of his
accusers died of suicide he's like I
might murder this person kill him with
but also Ethan you cannot eat on the
show look at the flipside of what that
would be like let's say he didn't kill
anyone
I
I had like need to keep dying like I
look like a [ __ ] killer nothing
apparently he's gonna keep making these
videos like there's like well 10 more
people delegate I like to think of him
like opening the newspaper and he sees
another accuser died he's like God I'm
not doing this I think [ __ ] dying
better own up to he's got like four more
accusers who are talking to each others
like yo we could make the mine as well
[ __ ] off ourselves so I had like one
shot and I'm feeling pretty good yeah
let's go alright let's go we're in a rap
that's what you're saying nothing
matters how long has it been
dan how are 50 Oh time to play sport
night tell me when I can eat and work
then what's going to say that way yeah
leave that up to Dan we cannot eat on
the show I feel bad doing that because I
eat the chips all the time I'm trying to
blast through these topics impose when
it's part row yeah it was talking miss
name ever you know the story behind its
solely its her initials and she says
also chuckles companies have owes and
them right face boot right cue cool so
I'm gonna make coop and I'm gonna like
they say that all successful companies
haven't yet have to over I it was in
Howard Stern interview so she said
Gwyneth Paltrow with ok but goop sounds
like it's not a good sound but goop is
successful right Barry yeah yeah I guess
she wasn't wrong at that number again
she wasn't wrong well you know when
you're when you're selling it to crazy
people it's very mom's yeah
crazy mom it's a lot of well it's the
same it's the same I catch a good market
do you I think it like anti-vaxxers a
stretch but it's people who like like
live and breathe Herbal Essence [ __ ] it
can't just be crazy like there's got to
be some actual wives mom well a lot of
people just admire her probably from her
movies oh that's yeah she has market she
sounds like brushes and stuff to which I
mean like if it's she's like well made
and it's not like a vagina
yeah yeah sure no here's my conspiracy
theory I think that she does these
marketing ploys they get publicity the
vagina egg was one that we all talked
about right now this one she made a
camel called smells like my vagina $75
candle smells like a vagina you I didn't
even say my theory oh well you said that
it's a marketing okay
well then you don't get up game breaks
and you're gonna wait for me to eat it
is there like an opinion about this you
should not eat during the show course I
shouldn't right now I'm not gonna tell
not eat during the show you kidding me
my take is that it's $75 it's sold out
immediately right we tried to find one
on eBay after sell markets I would have
spent $300 on this vision I'll buy
bloggers who code talk about why it
smells weird
vagina at all I tried to buy one I
couldn't find anywhere I concluded that
they never actually sold this candle mmm
they never even made it okay go ahead
you look I disagree with you because
it's not such a hot product like that it
would be on eBay now you know what I
mean I think it's just a gag product and
I could see people buying it because
it's like kind of funny it's brazen I
mean how many could they have possibly
made the woman has one vagina
how much smoking you get out of my job
back I actually thought she squirted in
the wax recipe no but you run you got to
drink a lot of water I mean she's a busy
woman he went for a run then she was
like I got real stinky then she squirted
the whole Paltrow on wax like an old
vagina egg comes out so do you think
people would buy handle that I just in
yeah smells like dry cement people would
buy that or what's what's the man
equipment smells like baba ghanoush
smells like mine baba ghanoush oh yeah
Meg mother you go yeah you're not
circumcised are you guys circumcised
yes you are these there no you're not no
do you get you magma no
that is such a goddamn mirror that's
such a mere Meg
tell me because I've heard guys say they
have dick cheese yeah those guys don't
wash their dicks so you have to peel the
skin back and wash you peel this but
it's not that big a video it's like
that's like fingernails getting [ __ ]
under them that's like clean
you know you clean them but I'd rather
not you know you take toenail clippers
you clip your foreskin back and it grows
back I learned that analogy makes me
feel like it's gross because I have a
hard time cleaning under my nails really
and under the nails is pretty gross I
just like Brody you know yeah I mean
it's supposed to your penis supposed to
be black right if you're black [ __ ] I'm
not black that's gangrene or dirt
whatever it is have you found keeping
things you I do regret not being
circumcised not at all no I mean I it's
it's so weird that it's even a
conversation because it's not your
choice like my parents chose it I
wouldn't be right
you guys parents chose that you would be
like as a non circumcised person you
watch porn every penis morning sir
that's American thing and you're like
that's not what it looks like when I do
it it's like hey there's a bit of a
disconnect that keeps me and relate oh
you know it just keeps a few pulled in
do you look for uncircumcised forever no
not really do you when you find a man
porn star who has an uncircumcised penis
do you feel good actually
couldn't tell you a single mil porn
stars named part couldn't tell you a
single stars name that hasn't been in
like a movie like Sasha Grey I know that
one she had like a whole TV show didn't
she well she was on away she was in that
Steven Soderbergh movie what's that got
to do with uncircumcised penis well just
I don't know anyone's don't keep your
house I go to I go to uh but yeah that
guy calm and I'm like all right what's
hot why are they all steps is lazy it's
a big damn it
alright I'm gonna pretend this isn't a
step-sister yeah - use your imagination
while watching and alright I like this I
would lose the stepsister angle see I go
step further I pretend she is I make my
own
damnit commit I don't like the idea of
any divorce going up this mystery person
who was circumsized and as an adult says
that their sensation their gratification
from sex is not diminished no I'm just
saying because people that's what people
say and I'm happy to report that we
still got it I think like you're trying
to talk Eric into it well I I would have
I know a good guy
begin with like I can't say to anyone
who's circumcised that my sex is more
pleasurable than theirs because how
could you I don't have the lies before
an affray
no and he reported back that's like
someone who died and then reported back
from Africa right and it's incredible
you don't get that that's a TLC show
dude like after a cut that's a good show
my in high school this is how many
people are just circumcised Dan like to
say that your uncircumcised is like what
a fart in high school it just casually
came up and everybody just started
calling me a coffee
uncut what Wow people give you uncut
I got uncut put in my nickname my
nickname was javi and my important work
one of the classes I had was the school
newspaper and my column was Hoffy uncut
I got away with being like well no it's
because I'm an unfiltered you know I'm
like a real genius and everybody when
they got the first one was like what the
[ __ ] that's awesome yeah you embrace
that's about my penis you embrace the
nickname oh yeah cuz it's funny penises
are funny anything about penises butts
it's like that Rick and Morty quote like
it's funny when they're big it's funny
when they are small yeah like yeah any
kind of penis there's just the shadow of
a penis
that's funny Oh funny funny funny yeah
you ever seen with somebody sitting
there and you just have a shadow of a
penis behind them it makes no sense it's
super fun but I'm gonna laugh every time
yeah glory holes just seeing a Gloria
there's no penis at all comedy the whole
herd about then he apologize efforts of
God he made an apology I don't think
anyone yeah by the way the security
dropped the ball there they should have
rope punched her and to say that he
slapped her yeah an exaggeration he did
if he slapped the one down
can you imagine actually having a whole
segment look at this creep who's gonna
about to explain what let's see what
this guy breaks down the folks I've
never anyway seen him lose its temper in
any in any way I love that Tim sex
tonight entirely unprecedented we've
seen the Pope react in uncomfortable
situations this way before we don't know
how to [ __ ] analysis-- is in
something now and I loved it boring
dystopia 101 we got like a flapper CNN
cNN has not had a hot year well you can
tell that let's watch that Bernie of the
warran moment from the debate because it
was iconic where they go they go Bernie
did you say that a woman can't be
President he said no I didn't say that
and then they go to Warren and says
Warren Warren what did you think when
Bernie said to you that women can't be
President yeah that was bizarre that's
doing him dirty a little what does this
have to do with you the question a story
yeah
so it's their story and they brought
it's like with this whole viral moment
yes the very moment they created
got themselves there you see this - this
is great
Tom I thought were here where they still
miked on this yes I'll play you what
they said and Tom saw what the [ __ ] and
they just find what I want to watch yeah
I find the clip of them off the mic and
find the clip of that
exchange I have mentioned before does
that make sense what I've just said yes
oh my god
wouldn't you think is that bathwater
spit spit I want a gag smell I wouldn't
open that now but yes we're owner gag
that triggered me [ __ ]
how much was that's the price you sent
it for free yeah that was lucky
we're the only Wow god damn so jealous
please don't do 23 me or anything like
that the car would tell you that when
she's selling it that every dollar she
that's a one-of-a-kind and then we got
this as an exclusive we should do is you
should spit in it and do 23andme oh
should I spit and Center my spit I
didn't think that you should collections
rule for like an inert leader Dan did
you copy my request can you find the
clip of the Pope no see we're past the
pulp can you find a clip in the debate
when they said Bernie they get some
footage from the debate they take it
down
what sock puppets it's fine
all right what a bunch of consoles oh
yeah do you know what they said she said
she said I believe you just cook there's
me being a liar now watch TV and he said
let's talk about this later
Yeah right and then story was like hi
Bernie I just want to say how you like
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay good you Mike
you better get away from me no you're
doing [ __ ] a warrior yeah everyone's
trying to come at Bernie yeah he's gonna
I had a dream that he went all day do
your dreams come true often like you're
literal literal dreams um I don't
usually have prophetic dreams okay
mmm so maybe this could be my first
prophetic dream that would be a good one
so I actually became I've been a staunch
yang supporter mm-hmm
you know first of all I'm yanking
ride-or-die for life but if that does
pan out and he wasn't in the last debate
so I was thinking Bernie Sanders I woke
up and I was like Bernie [ __ ] Sanders
for president you gonna become president
well those are my two favorite options
for sure
yank him here right yeah twice twice
baby you're sitting in [ __ ] [ __ ] no I do
feel ya tingle there's a yang Farley or
do you not like to talk about what do
you guys like I feel like I am a
politically are you educating the Trump
supporter it's so much obviously I'm big
no I'm just be like I'm not um I'm more
left-leaning I'm more left-leaning but I
I don't feel like I'm educated enough to
really have an opinion on you know are
you gonna vote no trimer I'll probably
vote yeah I will I will vote okay I get
it you don't talk about it Eric I'm vote
for Warren no you're not no you're not
really [ __ ] nut or Bernie I don't know
yeah you're gonna vote for Warren I like
Warren there's nothing wrong with liking
someone others planning but she played
it so dirty Bernie so dirty I know that
was pretty dirty the difference is like
I don't hate I can't heal okay it's
whatever I liked Warren I like I like I
like was kind of [ __ ] I like Warren
a couple years ago but the thing that I
don't like about Warren is that I just
feel like she's not very likable and so
I feel like she will definitely lose
yeah maybe
no no but Bernie he's got that vote in
California so it doesn't fight if you
got to choose between Warren and Bernie
you're choosing Warren if I choose well
you know I got time to make up my mind
Brian yeah it was there it was a lot
more I was a lot more certain about that
before she did that thing where she said
Bernie told her woman could never win
what just outrageous wait
did say that well I think if I had know
what was the context like it's a very
strange thing I think we all know that
Bernie stands for good modern like yeah
Society no
why would he say something about what
was the contact what hate is how like
such a location so quiet
we're like if you and a lot of its
Twitter where they make up this never
Warren yeah never warm it's like well
maybe Warren yeah sometimes Warren I
don't think she I don't think she has a
chance and I know that like me just
saying that I like Warren is gonna be
like Oh for Carrick like there's some
people they're gonna feel that way and
it's a yeah why do you care so much
about something that I truly don't care
that much about it's like I made up my
mind a while ago that's just how I feel
politics are not everything and people
make it to my dad so people really put a
lot of their emotional stake into
politics which should be like one of the
most boring facets federalized it was so
much nicer when it was born yeah it was
so nice I will agree with you now we
wake up and we check the news no this
guy said this and all where's this going
on it's not elite anywhere oh this is
exciting it's like you know there's more
there's more going on we're boring again
my [ __ ] mod and on it I just I pick
who I like and I continue to like them
until they do something stupid enough
that I don't like them anymore em hmm
and then a lot of my friends have that
same mentality like you know I go see
Marvel movies and theaters I yeah I
[ __ ] play shitty first-person shooter
video games not everything's gotta be
are you Joe I'm a regular guy I don't
get it I thought you were like so
complicated no you're right you're
making too much sense so I'm gonna have
to cut you off
I'm have to edit that out but I mean I
might you know if so you're not gonna
tell us now that I confessed I want to
say he's got a family-friendly channel
he won't even say he thinks kpop
definitely one for Trump ready Trump
into the Democratic primary I'm trying
man someone's gotta get him in there is
they do you know do you think that the
band
[Music]
hooray I might forget that maybe it's
better I forgot the name okay forget
about her Justin Bieber has been her
gagging his fans yeah that is song yummy
which by the way is so awful I somehow
still have not yet I know it worked on
it I had to go see you last night I had
to go see it went to the theater yummy
$8.00 watch yummy
sorry what are you talking about music
videos yeah what did you watch porn yeah
it's awful and it's not gone number one
and so he's upset that the song hasn't
gone number one so he's been begging his
fans he's posted like a thousand times
on Instagram but this was the best one
on Spotify he says create a playlist
with yummy on repeat and stream it don't
mute it play it at low volume let it
play while you sleep if you are not from
the US you can download a VPN into US
and then create a spot so he's gaming
the system so new imagine Bieber posting
that official introduces official
Instagram and he I think it's try to
beat its tried to have been justified
that it was a fan account that made this
post and he just like retweeted or
reposted it but doesn't matter well
exactly
so youtuber Danny Gonzalez made a
wonderful video either yesterday or the
day before detailing this entire thing
so it's not just these cringy ass like
gaming the system post that Justin's
doing also on his youtube channel on
Justin's YouTube channel for real he's
uploaded no fewer than like 10 versions
of the song they'd like to get more
views to get more views there's so
there's the official yeah yeah there's
the official music video there's the
lyric music video though everywhere so
there's the food fight music video then
there's the reaction video then there's
a Lele pons
oh yeah he's been colliding yes I didn't
see my Bieber video there
there's an Eric Hofstede Bieber video
yummy-yummy well yeah you ate it [ __ ]
oh I did yeah
I believe YouTube's allowed that I know
you really break the rules when you're
famous that says Kevin Spacey Kevin
Spacey probably wanted to collab with so
there's like it's like little nas X but
like wait worse
so wait an animated cannot hold three
further record this song and music video
suck I still haven't watched it I wish I
could play back I haven't have even
heard can I dance players or them and
then just yeah that's so boy the lyrics
are literally she got that yummy yummy
yeah yummy yum yum yum and the music
video is him eating desserts while
they're rotating people had a table that
he's on like people rotate out but I
guess it's about eating vagina yeah I
get out I mean what else but what
doesn't like dessert these may be eatin
boobies no it's about [ __ ] that's the
best way to describe eating ass you know
you got that yummy yummy yum yum I guess
well he just got married so girly that
girl's got a [ __ ] I keep forgetting
he's married probably cuz he's writing
[ __ ] like yummy that's the song you pick
I would think that after marriage and
three years of going off the grid he
would come back with a little refinement
and maturity maybe it's the flavor
styles of brothers how they kind of like
grew up with their night right no yummy
yummy I'm begging everybody to stream it
I was like damn I expected an evolution
Michael Douglas should set this kid down
and be like now listen oh you do that
too much good job Michael Douglas blamed
his his throat cancer yeah oh yeah
eating house yeah he was like yeah get
HPV in your throat he that's that's
pretty much what he said but then
everybody was like now
that's kind of crazy man you can't blame
your ex-wife's vagina
well he was probably eating strange
vagina if he got yeah that's true I
guess people made the made that leap and
turns out he was really just running
around town like eating just mouth open
yeah so you doing dental dams man gotta
look into those so that's that what are
those look i-i've actually no I heard of
those since I'm [ __ ] health class and
yes exactly exactly I feel like they're
in theory they exist but no one actually
uses them actually do I think it's like
saran wrap I mean I mean look like
high-tech swine flu hung it's too whole
event well we just put a condom on your
tongues not good enough I don't think
that I don't think that's good enough
now do you trust me don't do that oh my
god look at this photo
what that can't be real that's what it
is I literally have never seen that
what's going on I'm not putting my dick
in that that's that's for eatin yeah
that is a nightmare fuel goddamn bro
this is the best click on that woman's
face with the [ __ ] face thing oh my
god it looks like a little trampoline
that's what you see when you die do love
me Charles yeah you know what he's doing
usually back this with my Dennis doesn't
let me find it like this how long are we
going then we're at Dan I can give you
for chrissake we're at 212 Mike so Jules
at the same time oh it's like smoking a
cigar thank you
so okay what's your what's your dueling
experience like like is it favorable to
you just nicotine replacement it works
yeah do you feel like woozy or
lightheaded ever when you do it or no
not really I mean it I was smoking
cigarettes for like better part of a
decade so it's basically just replacing
the how long you been off
I can't remember my last cigarette
that's really it's pretty good yeah it
is very nice I wish that was probably
awesome let's see
Khalid crowd surfing we can end it
really is there anything else guys
of course you know what else go ahead
Jeff
no I'm just I'm in clean clothes in Star
Wars yeah I did not I [ __ ] hate that
series man they [ __ ] that up huh
I was already really dumb they made a
dumber what's so bad and then just sea
bass my favorite one people say that
about the finale really my favorite even
over the original and I'm like yeah
can't really you should be castrated I
haven't seen it but I just because the
reviews have been so underwhelming now
we're a responses you get spoilers it's
like oh I already know it happens I know
who lives and dies and whatever but like
I I don't really have an interest in
seeing it what if what a [ __ ] that's a
shame right had Star Wars here's a novel
concept when you plan a trilogy maybe
know what the story for the trilogy is
gonna be cuz they like that's sorry that
they didn't know after I walked out his
second one you wanted well no like what
he said oh yeah I was like god dammit
I [ __ ] this off aren't they but the
force awakens I was like well this is
quaint
alright let's write we're wrapping it up
yeah okay the second one I was like oh
they don't know this is like we're
having conversations are you all right
dude I don't know why I just started
sweating leave some water here you want
a jewel jewel help of my lung whole
class ela say goodbye welcome back well
you guys got planned for 2023 this
episodes
good luck this is how we starting the
year well it wasn't really that bad no
it's great we have the fantastic Jack
and Eric what do you guys want to do for
2020 like what are your goal bomb the
White House
why did I say that you have that on lock
Wow I'm not gonna let me add it this a
follow up yeah you know Secret Service
goals are to grind work raise a baby
breathe maybe you're taking day Renee
I'm just taking a day by day it's not a
bill Burke oh that's a good approach oh
yeah what are yours what's your goal
2020 I want to get weird and like
diversify a bit more uh like oh yeah
maybe a little less of the YouTube game
a little more of like other other fields
so that's what what do you got you got
some rough yeah it can be it can be
taxing on the brain and the soul oh yeah
you know I mean although by the way I
want to give it up to you
for that incredible Twitter song you
made what the [ __ ] how did you make that
was that your intention from the
beginning um from the first two months
it was not the first to mow I literally
who was just going to be Twitter for
Android forever for the rest of the year
so because I wanted to see what the end
game would look like my number but I
realized at the midpoint in February
that it just kept looking the same as
the night right the maximum trip eNOS so
like I can't be doing this for 10 more
months so that's when in mid-february I
decided well I'll change it up and make
a song out of it so I had a like plan
was so good rest of the song you know
and it looked amazing the editing was so
good man how long not long at all it's
actually quite simple editing yeah like
the hardest part was just the most
tedious part was arranging 365 slide
that an aura yeah but making him I'll
dance and rotate and you doesn't mean
it's out it's not hard that's not too
bad because you just make little see how
long it take you to place a trillion
tweets oh that that was ok so it would
take me about a minute each day to like
tweet it out because I don't have to
remember like okay what I do yesterday
because this
I have to use this word or this phrase 8
times I know it was like for musical
structure you do 8 8 8 something alright
this is day 5 of 8 you keep in check you
have to keep track that's tucked that
wasn't fun and I would never do this
again because the the worst part was
this little project Twitter for Android
made my year zoom by made my 20 nitrous
thing really fast and I didn't like that
feeling it uh like I want to like enjoy
and take my time and I like running so
I'll never do it again I'm glad I did it
once it was cool ever do that is a great
project that's a chance to take on like
doing something people are like you know
I watched a movie every day this year
but like yeah that probably made their
year seem like yeah you can't just have
a day anytime you have stat level of
structure I think it makes the time go
by really yeah yeah from experience it
really [ __ ] did so it's a cool it was
cool gimmick I'm glad I did it but I
would not recommend anyone ever do
anything like that again I don't know
the history and so what and so what are
we diversifying until a couple of things
I want to I want to try one try podcast
with Oh excellent wife Erin whoa what
are you gonna do have a name for it yeah
I mean I something along the lines of
the Erin show with Jack because it's
really just the whole thing you know her
she is quite the personality she's got
charisma and and character out the wazoo
so he can so highly of your wife or nah
man it's true right so we're gonna work
on that and then I'm a couple a couple
of other things like I'm trying to make
a little weird game engine thing on
Twitch gonna hopefully work on it app
gonna oh do him no active [ __ ] no tube
sounds like good yeah I got a tour the
spring oh there's so what you guys have
to see Jack show music what is it no
music it's cool so that's a it's not a
typical like youtuber show where it's
like jacksFilms fans come one and all
and I'll do inside jokes for 90 minutes
I didn't want to do that so this is more
of like an interact in tarako live game
show so if you come on if you have a
smartphone you can play this little game
so it's kind of like jack box on
steroids so it's like your name's Jack
and so it's a match up in a didn't
happen so
people are gonna be like yeah it's like
jacket there yeah yeah you don't know
jack I'm gonna say so it's basically
like I'm on stage on the host there's a
question behind me like very exploitable
question like describe your ex turn
forwards or whatever and so you whip out
your phone and everyone in the audience
in the theater like submits their
answers then we have people backstage
going through all the hundreds of
answers and they pick out like they're
the best for I project the best for
behind me and then it's like all right
guys out of these four what's the best
one vote now what about your phone again
you vote whoever wins we pull up on
stage we pull up like five people on
stage total and then we go head to head
and around called are you funnier than a
youtuber so MN Lima get against me so
like wow that's a lot of things you had
a question yeah it is is but it's like
one by one people get knocked off it's
very tightly formatted it was it was
like you guys were doing like a test run
I guess what that was we did test it was
tight
it was tightly packed it was nice thank
you what can I come see
I think we're shooting for me so every
show is gonna be different by the nature
of exactly on YouTube I'm sure we'll
have like a highlight reel on YouTube
yeah absolutely a best-of or like a
highlight it's like here's what you
missed yeah and like you could stay for
multiple shows and see a different show
every time it's very unique yeah so on
on that November date we did two shows
we did an all-ages show and then at 21
an up show and as you can imagine the
answers were wildly different and I
gotta say I was pleasantly surprised at
21 up show was where it's at people were
getting rowdy but like oh my god
anyways well that's exciting yeah I was
2020 what about you man I'm gonna go see
Jack perform live in May where are you
yeah but like we're very excited for hey
thanks man um I got nothing going on
this year that's not true you got
lessons to teach I want to do fun stuff
I want to uh uh write a book [ __ ] yeah
oh I would read that book in an instant
write a book like a comedy book yeah
like no yet I don't know all right good
I feel like because you would actually
write in the book yeah I want to do why
I already know the hotel I'm gonna go to
I'm gonna do like a little writer's
retreat Oh weeks just sit down and write
the hotel has a bar in the basement
it's in Pennsylvania I stayed in it once
for a friend's wedding and they gave me
this room that was like wild it was not
like a normal hotel it was like a
person's house that had become a hotel
later in its life I was staying in the
upstairs area and I was like this place
is the bomb they have a bar in the
basement I'm coming back here and I
don't know why or for what and then I
was started getting the bug to like just
and right and not have my face you want
to write on the Opera I don't know if
it's a novel maybe it's like a bunch of
short stories maybe it's a nonfiction
crime thriller probably not that one
I don't know too much about crime we're
thrillers okay or fiction or non not to
suck your dick too much man but like you
have a you have quite the talent for
writing and it's not one away from that
no but it's videos because like when you
write a comedy with words I used to do
those things where I'd be the Viking
character and like write a short story
and that was just me like drunk like
writing a short story and being like hey
I like this and with a little bit of
editing it could have been like a good
short story but instead I would just
leave it as a youtube comment down so
funny it's [ __ ] Facebook but those
are fun that's I think that's what I
started with creatively when I was a kid
that's always been my draw to like you
know right interesting
no not necessarily be part of it or like
write for myself or be like an actor
that I'm writing for it because now all
I write is like a script mm-hmm it's
like to sit down and actually like right
you know like fiction or like write a
story down you can make anything happen
like when I write a script them stuck in
my room yeah at my desk I've got my
computer and I have to make a dick joke
it's like a little limit see right
little limit yeah and it's very fun I'm
not mad at it but at the same time like
to sit down and like
like a you know a horror story or just
some story about a guy in a boat you
know like the simplest things you can
like you can paint them a certain way
like how many people have done like
stories about these simple [ __ ]
things that we do and made it seem like
poetry and it's always like really
interesting to read different takes on
it but what if it sucks though it won't
whatever you guys are like super honest
so you like like hey we read your book
[Laughter]
yeah I will I think that's how it works
right you said everyone but you know
it's it's very easy to talk about plans
yeah this is very in fact sometimes I
think this is why I don't I think
talking about your plans delays them
just by the nature talking like in your
head you do this they have actually seen
us or think maybe it was a study I could
be making it up too but it seems to make
sense they says if you have a goal you
want to achieve
don't tell anybody because when you
speak the goal to people then you get
the sense that you've already
accomplished it and then it makes you
less motivated to do it
Wow so in this case I just did it so not
right yeah it will come out of this well
then you're not gonna do it we're gonna
have plans but you know I I think I I'm
happy with the transition we made I do
miss making youtube videos but then I
think like I I really want to go and
make a youtube video like every month
but then I remember just what a headache
and all the mad [ __ ] things that come
with it would you ever consider hiring
writers and
you know I would but then I already have
with between the clothing company and
this yeah like I I start going down that
path I was like oh I could do all these
things but then I'm like oh that's just
gonna turn into like it's just gonna
make my life miserable
I feel like unless you always have to be
involved you can't outsource everything
you will be involved for sure but I
think it's a possibility if you really
look at it in a whole new way and in a
way that allows your time of involvement
to be very particularly you show up to
record and then you just I'm gonna give
it to you go over the edit or something
very like you know calculated because
the way we used to do it we can't do
anymore it's just not but you about like
what if you just you come back when you
want like yeah yeah if you feel so
inspired to make a video about a certain
subject our process was such a nightmare
okay was always so negative just to
shoot and anything and coming up with
the idea and it takes a long time now we
have a baby like oh the baby actually
don't have as much time as we it would
have to be a situation where you walk
into it
pre-lit okay everything's blocked out
like you have an X on the ground that
you stand do your bit I mean and like
will that feel the same no we would have
to be different yeah but but maybe the
audience doesn't care they like it the
same which could be possibly but I don't
know it would be a different thing
yeah I would be different yeah I think I
really liked this guy ray william
johnson oh yeah this kid he's popping up
right he's really shooting up the ranks
I love his comic book wall
very impressed with the amount of comic
books he's a crude which i think is
actually no no [ __ ] I think it's
actually Watchmen behind him I think
pages that fall Watchmen it's not watch
and I know that because I had to
recreate it for an old RWJ parody I did
like 10 [ __ ] years ago and I I think
it's I think it's Watchmen if you zoom
and enhance and I would love for DC
Comics to like go through you didn't get
the right uses that dress hair goddam
YouTube channel with our [ __ ] comic
books and you never paid royalties I
think he hates me
I tried to get him on the show once and
he poo pooed me so bad and he's friends
with Jeff Dunham by the way who was uh
with love not before that wall yeah not
my favorite oh my god that comic-book
wall the hey what if I did think we need
a feel oh we have to go
what if what if Achmed the undead
terrorists joined Isis and why does he
never try to kill Jeff Dunham he joins
Isis and he suicide bombs himself sick
epic Johnson joke uh Jeff Kent though a
theme song room just so good so catchy
no Isis took so long so I'm gonna play
the ISIS theme song as you better end it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]